[Music]  summer  this one started out just like the last  one  so excited about tonight what you got  going till then gotta go see my mom i'm  better i've been better for months maybe  you could just come home then ain't that  easy baby girl  we didn't know it yet  hey chris  do i know you  but this summer  [Music]  hey leave him alone  was about to be very different  if i tell you what i have to tell you  you have to promise to believe me no  matter what  oh what is science i got attacked oh my  god are you okay a group of homeless  vampires  [ __ ]  i didn't know who was responsible but i  was going to make him pay  there's fire and decapitation got your  house back maybe we should just go i  think we'll use a wooden stake what  they're vampires duh  i had a plan  revenge  look deep into my eyes  do you know where you are  i can't remember  go  go  home oh my god  [Music]  hey  [Music]  you